we learned overnight that a preliminary
report on the Ethiopian Airlines crash
says the flight crew followed all of
Boeing's emergency procedures but still
could not control the jet investigators
in Ethiopia say the 737 max eight was in
good flying condition when it went down
last month killing all 157 on board the
initial findings also show flight
sensors on the plane were not damaged
boeing has grounded its max jets because
of software problems linked to two
crashes that killed more than 300 people
Kris Van Cleave is at Washington's
Reagan National Airport with details of
what we have learned Chris good morning
it seems like a new disclosure every day
well good morning and of course we
didn't get the actual preliminary report
that hasn't been released yet but the
update today is by far the most detailed
we've had since this crash now Ethiopian
Airlines says the report will clearly
show it's pilots followed all of the
emergency procedures but there are also
clearly lingering questions so safety
recommendations has been provided in an
early morning briefing investigators say
Ethiopian flight 302 started normally
but shortly after takeoff the plane
entered into a dive sources believe a
sensor malfunction triggering the MK s
anti-stall feature on the 737 max
Ethiopia's Transport Minister confirmed
the pilots followed Boeing's emergency
procedure and turned off M casts but
could not regain control
the pilots appeared to then deviate from
the emergency procedure by turning the
system back on M Cass reactivated and
the plane persistently nosedived turning
a system back on if in fact it was
malfunctioning is an unusual step 737
captain Dennis taser is the spokesman
for American Airlines pilot Association
he says the pilots may have felt like
they were running out of options and
running out of time emergency like this
that M casts off doors a monster it
comes in quick it comes in firm and it
has a very aggressive nose down limit
Boeing in the FAA told pilots after last
year's lion air crash in Indonesia
deactivating M casts and taking over
manually should be sufficient to prevent
disaster that worked for the crew who
flew the lion air 737 max the day before
that crash yesterday Boeing CEO Dennis
Muhlenberg tweeted photos aboard
test flight for the updated MKS software
on a 737 max he says it performed well
in action but the fix needs several more
weeks of work before it'll be sent to
the FAA for approval Taser says there
are still a lot of unanswered questions
before the max can fly again granted the
software change is supposed to take a
lot of this out but it sounds like there
there may be more things that are going
to need proper review before we can take
on this aircraft confidently as we did
before these tragedies Boeing says it
will continue testing the software as
it's being perfected now the FAA
announced an additional outside review
led by a former NTSB chairman into the
approval process surrounding the
automated flight control systems think
em Cass that will begin shortly this as
today one of the families of the eight
Americans who died in the crash plans to
speak as they announced a lawsuit
against Boeing gale figure that was
coming thank you very much Chris